[Music]
is re trying to steal Becca's thunder
now that is what some believe because
Ari and Lauren Kipnis announced their
wedding date yesterday right before
Becca's new season starts on Monday so
easy outlines lauren zima got Becca's
reaction i honestly don't care yeah yeah
it doesn't bother me I'm happy for them
good for them and and you know I'm just
focus on me and my journey and I do wish
them the best beau it's been just four
months since re broke Becca's heart and
ended their engagement but the 28 year
old is clearly over the drama she's even
been in touch with the couple and now
she has a new man in her life
you're engaged how she lit up and we got
to talk about that you're gonna marry
this guy I better marry that he better
bury me here 28 guys do you fall in love
with more than one person I did fall for
two guys at the end yes Becca won't
reveal if she said I love you to more
than one man but she did admit she has
more of an understanding of what Arie
went through until you're in this
position you don't realize how much
pressure there really is and how
difficult it is to navigate certain
relationships this is my time my turn
my choice you'll give every type of
emotion I will cry a lot I'll laugh a
lot
I swear sometimes I'll make some dirty
jokes that my mom will not like I'm
excited to watch it back honestly and
based on this sneak peek from the
premiere we could see why oh my gosh
Beca when I heard you were the
Bachelorette I literally died
what can you rock me back to life Oh
Glover that's a new energy me that is no
army no bye see you later
you